[Music]
Stace what do you make of all this oh my
goodness and it's kind of like the old
soap operas the Bulls turn I'm sitting
there watching with my grandma OOP
what's the reaction locally here I think
it's I think the city is is really
frustrated with the way the team has
played its been up and down you know all
season long has been very inconsistent I
think they're frustrated with Fred
Hoiberg you know it's just overall
frustration with the whole the whole
situation down here and I think it just
kind of kind of blew up you know after
this last game Atlanta and you're up 10
points with you know probably under two
minutes to go and they find a way to
lose and I think that you know
frustrations grew over in the locker
room and guys you know spoke their mind
I'm not a big fan of that I'm not a big
fan going to the media Colin teammates
out you know God like Dwyane Wade is
when three championships has a little
bit more weight than you know most guys
to do that its future Hall of Famer but
I think those things are left better you
know stay in the locker room to guys
face if you want to motivate somebody I
don't think you do it that way houses
play on Stacey because something has to
give here Hoiberg it feels like it is on
thin ice Rondo feels like one foot out
the door and Dwyane Wade and Jimmy
Butler it's not working and are you
going to get into a rebuilding mode here
in Chicago really soon well I think I
think they're thinking about that now
this is this has been the second year in
the row you know I like Fred Hoiberg I
think he's a very good young coach he
came to a team where guys are you know
they're set in their ways you know he
comes to a young team like a Minnesota
you know or Los Angeles Lakers where he
could put his stamp on a team we came to
attain that you know I had 150 games we
played four in a one of the top coaches
in the league of time and Tom Thibodeau
but these guys were used to a rigid
style of coaching coaching you know
where you know kind of like I'm getting
in your face I'm yelling at you and
screaming at you and you look at Fred
he's not liking it doesn't have that
type of personality person I'd love to
play for a guy like Fred because you let
you play a game play your game but these
guys have not bought into what
his approach and I don't think it's
clear to him I don't think he's had a
fair chance and I think it's been some
stubbornness on certain players to to
buy into what he's trying to do and as
long as that's going to happen you have
to make changes if you're either happen
you know make it a good coat so you're
going to have to blow up the team and
say hey you know what let's give this
guy a young team let's start from
scratch and let's rebuild and start our
movement like Philadelphia and some of
these does los angeles lakers and go
younger but you were there with phil
jackson and michael jordan and i know we
didn't have social media but how're
things discussed settled in the locker
room when there were disputes well
players handle the business themselves I
mean we trust me we had fistfights you
know behind the scenes no one knew about
me guys got after each other but you
know what we were we were solid group
that's the only way you can win
championships at you you gotta have
everybody on the same page and you know
players never called out players in the
media if anybody was gonna call out
anybody do you feel it would always get
you go go to sneak this isn't in the
press and you'd be like wow come on sale
because it told me that you know you see
now it feeling Carmelo I mean so when
you see what's going on down in New York
with the things that are being leaked
outed and they would have ways to get
your attention you know and so if
anybody was going to do that they would
be still in a professional way not in a
way to demean anybody or to you know
make them make a player feel like you
you know these worthless but this
situation our social being the way
things are in this generation these kids
that are playing in this league now they
feel like they got to tell everybody
what's going on you took the situation
in Cleveland with LeBron I mean LeBron
has the right to say what everyone sees
it is the best player in the league
right now but when you want a
championship last year and your gym was
the brain of gym and then this year
you're not winning now it's not a good
team so you gotta handle those things
in-house and you know you just got these
kids nowadays Danny you know I mean they
feel like they got to go on snapchat
they got to go in you know Instagram
they got to tell everything that's going
on and it's real sad but these are
veterans who are involved in this you
know Jimmy Butler Dwyane Wade and rajon
rondo they've been around the block or
two they're the ones that are
showing these younger kids how not to do
it that's what I find embarrassing about
Josh yeah I'm that's what I'm a little
bit disappointed in because you know
right regards to what people think about
Rhonda Rhino has been a great great team
making sure you know I've heard all the
stories about him you know these other
teams and I was a little skeptical when
we picked him up but and I'm around him
every day I mean he works with the young
players he's been a great mentor and
people have been waiting for him to
explode you know he got benched you know
a couple of weeks ago set out five games
he didn't he didn't blow up on the
sideline he didn't stop coming to games
I mean this is a guy who comes to events
even when he's not scheduled to be there
thanks give guys a night off he comes to
the practices with young player he even
goes to D League games to watch some of
the some of the kids that may not be
playing a lot to the bull that go down
in place for the Windy City bull this is
a guy who goes and watch these kids play
you know at the windy city bowl game
giving him some support so I can see
where he's coming from and I can see the
laneways frustration but at the end of
the day you know you got to be held
accountable you know this this thing
cannot happen if you're Fred Hoiberg
right now I don't know if it's too late
but you got to put your foot down and
you gotta lay the law down this can't be
happening you can't be airing your dirty
laundry out like you know bunch of
schoolgirls and going to social media
talking about each other because it just
doesn't look like this is professional
sports it's not high school Stacy good
to talk to you as always and you know
maybe one day we'll have you on and
we're talking about fun things nice
thing good don't always feel like it's
like a movie monday night nice job you
just gotta under- I know I not be I
don't know I say to French the negative
stuff on the Bulls call Stacey King
Shantanu okay it seems like there but
always enjoy coming on different joke
but thank you stays Stacey King the
comcast sportsnet Bulls analysts there
the Dan Patrick show weekday morning on
audience
you